And council staff like to welcome Council Member
Amy Peck.
I can't even see that because the Claire so
at this time I'd like to welcome Director Kenneth Allen and Miss
Cheryl Johnson. Provide the
Houston Parks and Recreation Department budget. Good morning.
Good morning. Good morning. See, everybody is smiling and ready to go
right there. All right, well, good morning.
Thank you pro Tim and City Council
for just allowing us to present and your continuous support of
the Houston Parks and Recreation Department. Certainly over
the last three years, we've had to adjust and pivot
and make things work the best that we can.
Partnering with other directors, other partners,
has certainly been a challenge to deliver just regular parks
and recreation services. But when you think about us being as
Lily Paz, shelter sites, distribution sites,
just really doing things to accommodate the needs of the
public, I am so proud of the team that I have
the honor and pleasure of managing day to day.
And these are guys and women with boots on the ground that
are actually delittering our parks, actually mowing,
actually repairing roofs,
plumbing, and the staff that work with our children day
to day. I am so very proud of them because they go beyond
and above the call of duty. They work with the resources
that we have, sometime limited. But guess what?
They've made a way out of no way. And we do have some
gaps, but we are striving to continue to
provide services the best we can with what we have. So I
want to honor them and I want to thank them for their day to day
effort. It takes a huge coordination
effort with my executive team working hand
in hand with their direct reports. And I have them with me
today. I like to introduce have many of them with me today.
I like to introduce them with me. I have my security blanket,
so if there's a question I can't answer, I have Miss
Cheryl Johnson, our Deputy Director of Management
and Finance, our CFO. I have. Abel Gonzalez,
deputy director of Green space management.
Michael Eisenman, Deputy Director of Facilities Management and
Development. Have. Deborah Lathan, deputy director
of recreation operations. Have. Tom Angelos,
deputy assistant director of Recreation and Wellness.
I have Jason Harsh, division manager of our golf operations.
Tom Bourgeois, Division Manager of our Urban Park
Rangers. Estella Espinosa,
Communications Manager, and our Public Information Officer.
Erica Madison, our Administrative Coordinator. Mimi Rasmus,
also our Administrative Coordinator. Jerrell,
Washington Council Liaison. And also have
Lucy Carrera partnerships and legislative liaison. And also
we have Lisa Johnson, she's with GSD, but she's a Project
manager for Parks in terms of our capital projects.
Next slide, please.
Within our department, in our general fund, there are ten
main areas that has a combined total
of $86.6 million. In terms
of us operating with this proposed budget, that equates
to about 195.1 FTEs.
Those major areas are green Space Management with 22.6
million of the budget. Community center
operations, 11.9 million of the budget.
Recreation and wellness, 6.2 million.
Facilities management and development, 8.7 million.
Urban park rangers, 3.5 million.
Next slide, please. The Director's office
with 1 million. Our communications office with
771,000. We have our management
and finance team, 4.5 million.
Utilities and inventory,
15.2 million. The Houston Zoo,
12 million. Next slide,
please. Our mission is pretty holistic,
and it's to enhance the quality of urban life by providing safe,
well maintained parks and offering affordable programming
for our community. We provide fitness,
sports opportunities, nature,
conservation, environmental education,
cultural awareness, arts and crafts, as well as leisure programs,
social and specialty classes for youth,
teen, adults and seniors. And then we operate
by a standard of care, which is a mandatory requirement
for our after school and summer enrichment programs.
And then we provide free mills throughout the city for use summer
and fall. Through a federal grant
administered by the Texas Department of Agriculture.
We have security, operations and dispatch services for
H park, for pools, for community centers,
for other facilities throughout our system.
Next slide, please. We manage park
land expansions,
constructions, renovations, inspections,
maintenance of park facilities. We ensure compliance with
all part building codes, fire codes, health codes,
american with Disabilities Act. And then when you guys think about
it, our entire inventory,
we have maintenance, and we maintain over 39,000 acres
of land of parkland. This includes over 380
parks. And then we also take care of espionage,
urban forest, natural resources,
sports fields, trails, trees, and we also
maintain the grounds for the library as well as multi service
centers. Next slide, please.
That's a huge inventory, and it takes teamwork and working
together and working with council and partners to
adequately serve the public. We're short in some areas and
we'll identify those, but I want to go to our revenues by
fund. If you look at our proposed budget revenues
by Fund for FY 23, we have our general
fund budget, we're proposing 793,000.
We have Fund 2100, which is our revenue fund.
Our proposed budget is 3 million, and that's
actually for events, birthday parties,
park facilities, team registrations,
tree violation, fines, lake Houston rentals,
and the rentals for tennis centers in terms of revenue.
And then we have Fund 21 four, our golf revenue fund,
we're anticipating or expecting 7.8
million in revenue for Fund 21 five,
our maintenance, renewal and replacement, we're proposing
2.6 million. And then Fund
21 six, which is our bio greenways,
2021.4 million.
Next slide, please. Terms of FY
23 revenue and some of the highlights.
This is our proposed FY 23 budget. Compared to
our FY 22 estimate. You look at our
general fund 1000,
we're saying 1000 less.
So I know that's not significant, but the fact that it's it's
less wanted that to be known. Look at Fund
2100 special revenue, we're proposing to make
468,000
more. And this is budget revenue that's projected
because of pre pandemic trends.
Also contributions from the Astros Golf
Foundation for playground initiatives. So if you look at 21 four
in terms of golf revenue, in terms of highlights,
we're proposing 565,000.
We're hosting the Houston Open once again, and we're projected
to increase some streams of revenue for golf as a result
of the tournament and some of the things that we're doing with
the Open. We look at Fund 21 Five,
maintenance, renewal, and replacement.
We're projecting 300,000 contributions
again, from the Astros Golf Foundation. For neighborhood
park projects, we're looking at Fund 21 six,
bio greenways, we're projecting 270K
for that. Next slide, please.
Expenditures by fund. This is FY
20 three's budget compared to FY 22.
Look at Fund and I'll go in more detail with this slide as we move,
as we progress through the presentation. But if you look at Fund
1000, our general fund, we're looking at over 8 million in
expenses, right? You look at Fund 2100,
special revenue, fund 274k
in expenses, fund 21 Four,
our golf revenue Fund, looking at 894,000,
fund 21 Five, maintenance, renewal and replacement,
343,000. And Fund 21
six, our bio greenways 2020,
we're looking at 22,000 in expenses.
So next slide, please. Fund 1000,
FY 23 personnel versus non personnel.
Personnel is 54% of the budget. That's at 46.6
million. Non personnel is 46% of the budget
at 40 million. Next slide,
please. Special revenue,
2100. Personnel versus non personnel
for FY 23 personnel is 34%
of the budget at 1.1 million, and non personnel
is 66% of the budget at 2.2 million.
Next slide, please. So,
for our golf special revenue,
21 Four, personnel, 59% of
the budget at 4.7 million, and non personnel,
41% of the budget at 3.2 million.
Next slide, please.
For our maintenance, renewal and replacement, fund 21
Five, personnel is 35% of the budget at
1.1 million. And then we have non personnel at 65% of
the budget at 2.1 million.
Next slide, please. So,
Valo Greenways 2020, fund 21 six,
we have personnel at 83% of the budget at 1 million,
and we have non personnel at 17% of the budget at
212,000. Next slide,
please. So this slide actually is
it compares FY 22s budget to FY 23
proposed budget, and it describes the changes between
the budgets. Next slide, please.
If you look at when we focus on 22, as was an
adopted budget, the operating budget was
58 million. And then the restricted budget,
we looked at 9.5. And with a total
budget for FY 22, which was adopted at 67.2
million. And then moving from FY 22 adopted budget to
the FY 22 current change, we had the following adjustments
made. We had an restricted account and adjustments for
58 million. And then we had hope adjustments that
went to 726,000. And then
healthcare benefits. As far as active civilians,
there was a reduction actually of 103,000,
council surplus,
98,000. And then the zoo contract in
terms of annual payment, 10.5 million.
So after combining those adjustments, there was 11.3
million. And we got to our FY 22 current
budget of 78.6 million.
Next slide, please.
Moving from FY 22, our current budget to FY
23, we made the following budget adjustments.
You look at health care benefits for civilians and long term disability,
310,000. FY 22
Hope Allowances, we look at 251,023.
Hope allowance.
960,000. Minimum wage adjustments,
149,000. Municipal pension,
224. As far as a reduction,
so that was good news. You look at restricted accounts at
221,000, and then the Zoo CIP
increase at 520,000.
All right, we have new facility allowance. This is the A leaf, bringing that on
at 588,000. And then I
love our park initiatives that's been so beneficial to
neighborhoods, about 5 million. So we
get to the FY 23 proposed budget of 86.6
million, which is a 10.3% increase
for the current budget. Next slide, please.
We look at expenditures from 23. In terms of
expenditure highlights, we had some variances between
FY 23 and FY 22 budget.
All of the increases were due to Hope allowances,
minimum wage adjustments, and related benefits.
So explaining this by fund, you look at 1000,
our General fund. There's an $8 million
difference. This increase is in restricted accounts
and funding for the Mayor's Love Our Parks Initiative
Fund, 2100. Special revenue is 274,000.
And this is a purchase
of sports fill vehicles to maintain our fields and
our inventory for Fields fund 21 four.
As far as golf revenue, it's 894,000
for increased maintenance costs and upgrades to the course.
To ensure that we meet the PGA standard to deliver
the tournament here in Houston,
we have our maintenance renewal and replacement of 343,000.
This is due to an increase in maintenance and park maintenance and repair
cost. You look at fund 21 six,
greenway, greenways, 2020 of 34,000.
This is mainly the purchase of new vehicles and equipment.
This actually concludes our budget presentation.
I went through it pretty quick. You guys may have questions.
We also have some department demographics and accomplishments
in the appendix in the back.
I like to open this up for questions. I want to thank my team for
certainly joining me. That's behind me.
Thank you. Thank you. We have a couple of council members
in queue. We'll start off with council member Abby Cayman.
Thank you so much, Director. And the entire team.
Really quickly, on page 16, the health
benefit adjustment, the 103. Can you just explain a
little bit more on that?
Health benefits for active civilians in terms of the
reduction of 203 I'm sorry,
$103,000.
Could you elaborate on that for me, please? Yeah, it's mostly due to
when we look at the health benefits for the active civilians,
when people retire, your employees retire and we bring on new employees,
we budget them at the lowest health
benefit rate in hopes that they're going to come
in. And so we budget for just lower
than if somebody retire after being there 32, 35 years somewhere.
Okay, understood. I wasn't sure if that was a COVID correlation or what.
It just stood out to me. Thank you.
While we never wanted a pandemic,
still wish we weren't dealing with some of it. But one of the things that
came out of it was the greater appreciation I think we have for being outside
and the services that you all provide day in and day out for
our park system and not just the enjoyment of the outdoors, but Director,
to your point, the support we provide for our youth through
the Parks program I know you talked about the Meals program. Every year
I bring up one of my favorite programs we do at the city is the
after school programs, not only giving
kids a safe place to be while their parents
may still be at work, but the folks that work
in your department are providing tutoring crafts.
I remember one night I was at a civic club meeting at Cherryhurst,
and it had to be 1030 at night, and there was still an
employee there teaching one of the
kids how to play chess so that he could be on the school team.
And that dedication just changes lives.
So thank you for that really quickly.
Given the financial constraints that we continue to face
at the city, what are some of the needs that currently are
not being met, and is there anything you want to flag for council that may
be coming up in the future that we need to be aware of as a
need that is not sustainable right now. Based on this
budget in terms
of facility renovations and
park maintenance and reducing our moore's cycles,
we're currently on basically a 21 day
cycle for much of the park land throughout the city.
We do have some partnerships, and we're engaged with some community groups that
help us take care of parks, but that's one of the major things. We want
our parks in great condition,
but currently, because of staffing levels and budget,
we would love to reduce our mooring cycles.
That's number one.
And then two, in terms of delivering services,
we're limited to the amount of staff that we have at each location.
And so sometimes we're relocated to partnerships and opening
and closing doors, with our primary programming
being our after school program and then some specialty classes
where we invite other groups to come in. So we
have to do a lot of that, but mainly our Mourn
cycles and then support for our youth
in terms of programming, oh, I can't forget,
and he'll kill me if I walk out of here without saying it.
Our facilities in terms of upkeep
and maintenance, we have some aging facilities.
We need a lot, but we take care of them as best we can.
Thank you. Like to welcome council member Sally
Alcorn and Council member Carolyn Evan Chabaz to the horseshoe.
Council Member Amy Pick. Thank you, Mayor Pro TEM.
And thank you, Director for the presentation director. Has there ever
been a study to see if for the
Mowing of the Esplanades and the libraries and multi service centers, if working
with Public Works to leverage funds or contracts,
that kind of thing, would save any money?
We certainly encourage collaborations
and working together with other city departments,
the Esplanades are very
intense. We get to them like
a third priority after we mow the parks
and after we take care of other business. But that's
a critical area because we want them to look as nice as everything else.
As far as collaborating with Public Works,
I think they're just as limited as we are. We do
collaborate with neighborhood groups that want to maintain. That's been our
best way to kind of dig into the inventory
of espionage, but without partnering and us
being a solo on it. 22 to 24
days is what we are now based on resources. So we
welcome collaboration with any department or neighborhood
group to help us eat into that. Thank you.
Council Member Sally Alcorn. Thank you.
Along those same lines, on the performance measures in the budget book,
you have actually a target of 27 days on the mowing cycle.
And just back a couple of years ago, it was 21. And those
six days make a heck of a lot of difference. So I'm also interested
in, and I'm trying to find in
the raw data, where can I find the
mowing dollars? I mean, you have a landscape and gardening.
Do you remember the name of how you classify
mowing? It's not listed as mowing. Okay, you can get
that to me later. We can get that specific. And on the health benefits question
that Council member Cayman asked, I mean, I see consistently across all
departments a big savings in
health benefits. It's consistently over the years. And this is
a 400 million plus expense we do every year.
I know we want to have enough money for health benefits always,
but we're overdoing it by quite a bit, and then those savings are
passed back to the department. So that $103,000
is just because we're overstating what we think we're going to need on health benefits.
And I've seen that kind of across the board on that.
Okay? That's all I have. If you could just get the exact mowing costs,
I'd like to see that. And are they broken out by parks
and libraries and Esplanades, or is
it just kind of one?
It's actually in one. So green space management. So if
you look at the green space management budget, that's where you
have it. So we don't have really anything broken down. Now, some of them
have individual call centers, but not all parks have.
Okay, so just in the green space management. And one thing I know we've
talked to the city's naturalist about,
and thanks to Barbara Quattro, in a leaf,
she has brought up the linear forests,
putting more trees in the Esplanades so the grass isn't growing so high.
Also using more, we've had a big meeting with the natural
plantings in the esplanades, which don't require
as much mowing. So what is the department doing to further
those initiatives? One thing, in terms of partnerships with
neighborhoods and community groups, we have several of our
Espanas that are maintained by neighborhoods. So that definitely
help. They have to do it by park standard, of course,
in terms of what you're planning and how you're maintaining. But that's
been great over the years, and we hope to enhance that
effort. Thank you, Council Member Robert Gallegos.
Thank you, Chair. Talking about the esplanades as well.
First of all, I think you all do a pretty good job with the number
of esplanades you have in the city of Houston to try to keep all them
maintained. But there are two or three
esplanades over there by Gulf Gate. I know that the Pecan Park Civic
Club has complained, and I believe
it's because the esplanades are all concrete,
but the cracks have grass that's growing that's like 2ft
tall. So the civic
club, PECOM Park has complained about that.
So I'm hoping that can be addressed where they can go out.
And again, I know they don't go out there regularly due to the fact
that they're concreted over. It's not dirty
and grass or what have you, but in between the cracks, the grass does
grow and the grass kid you not. It's like 2ft tall.
So if that can be addressed, it'd be great.
Also, in regards to the golf special revenue fund or
the golf expenses, I know that the
Houston Golf Association took over Gus Worthham golf Course. It's still
a city golf course, and this
course was done back under the previous administration.
And what I thought it was like a trial basis to see if they
would be successful, and I think they've proven that they are successful.
Is there still discussion of maybe the Houston Golf Association
of taking over other city golf courses, even though
it will be city land, city property, but they would just
maintain it and manage it and what have you? No current
discussion as far as golf association taking over golf courses
with our involvement with the Astros Golf Foundation
and the Astros primarily at Memorial Golf is doing
great right now in terms of revenue. A lot of people are planning.
We're able to maintain the courses appropriately,
and then we do have Herman that's coming up pretty
soon in terms of consideration of operating in
November. So that may be on
the table soon. Okay, you put me back in. We'll put you back.
Include in queue council member Tasha Jackson.
Thank you. And thank you, Director Allen, for your presentation and
just all your work that you've been doing and working with my office on trying
to get our parks. Just understand where we're going with
the parks and the need. And I know we've done a lot of tours over
the past two months, the parks in my district.
And just talking to your staff, one of the things is we needed more staff.
You need more staff to cover some of the maintenance that's
needed within the parks. And so I'm just curious. I see that there's an increase
of 10.3%. We have the love our parks
initiative. So is the extra staff and the 5 million that's in the
Love Our Parks, or have you included additional staff? I know
our conversation was I know we need money, so we need to ask for what
we need. I just want to make sure that we're aligned.
And so is the additional staff in this budget. No additional
staff, but just resources and material to get
that type of work done and then outsourcing
as we need to, especially with the Love Our Parks initiative.
As we complete those projects. We have five more parks we're going
to this fiscal year. We did five last year.
But contracting out has been a way to complete
some of the projects and then just the raw material
that's needed for the upgrades, purchasing that.
So one of the ways I operate is I do, like, a pento budget
and like a Bentley budget. Like, what is your Bentley budget?
Because I'm sure this is a pento budget. What is it that you actually need?
I know my colleague asks those questions. What do you need to actually give
the community what they need? And that's parks that's functionable that they can
use. And so, of course, we've seen the parks in my district,
and I know my other colleagues have visited the parks. And so what is it
that you actually need to do your job? That's a
load of questions for me. With Houston being the
fourth largest city in a nation, we cover a
lot of territory for us to get
to 14 days or seven day
mourning cycle. It's going to take a tremendous amount of money for
us to get there. And then facility upgrades. When you think about
we have agent facilities, agent pools, it's immense.
I'll have to do a study or some type of
document that would assess all of our
facilities and then our programs, as well as things
that we need to upgrade. But I'll need
a little time to get that together for you. I don't want to just throw
out a number, and it's not nearly what
I need to tell you, but it's extensive. I will say that.
Okay. And I'm still waiting on my list from the parks that we tour so
I can get that dollar amount based upon what the community
said that they would like to see in the park. And that way we can
know what we need, and then we can advocate for those resources. And thank you.
You're welcome. Council Member David Robinson.
Thank you, chair and director. Thanks for everything you
do with the limited budget I think some of the comments we're hearing from around
the horseshoe just really underline how you
do so much with so little. And while we're talking about
things related to the request my council colleague just made,
time and money and personnel would solve a lot of
problems. So recognizing all that, I think
you're coming here with your presentation on the heels of the
discussion with the General Services Department. And some of
what we spoke about already today was deferred maintenance. And as
an observation, when one doesn't mow
the esplanade, that deferred maintenance becomes very obvious.
Witness my colleague, council Member Gallegos, with the problems
down by Gulf Gate and hear the things that we're saying
around town. So you hear from us all the time. In recognizing
that, I want to appreciate what you're doing with
limited dollars and all those special revenue
funds and special projects that are piled one on
top of the other. With our fast and wonderfully positive
changing City Mayor Turner's Parks
initiative, what we've done recently with celebrating the
Zoo, some of our Bayou Greenways initiatives, of course,
and with the golf program, to name a few.
I want to focus on some of what we've described already today as
master planning initiatives, whether that's the parks master
plan, whether that's a master plan for tennis, which I appreciate.
You've got a section in the appendix about other accomplishments
where you talk about as you know, what we've been working on with the tennis
program, and I just wondered if you can give a
little narrative overtone of how
you see things in that master planning
category of our parks facilities.
Because those, famously, as the Adage goes, a master
plan tends to get on a shelf and collect dust.
But what can we do to help you push forward?
Specifically, in my case, curious about tennis, but what can we do as a
council to support your good work? That's a great question,
because when you think about the history of our park system,
we've been through several different master plans and
initiatives moving forward. I think collectively,
if we look at all the directors in the other departments, one in Planning,
of course, one with GSD Public Works,
we're currently working together for the Love Our Parks initiative
in several different areas. So from a citywide perspective,
we look internally what we can do together for
improvements. And then from a more broad
perspective, we look at our partners, partners like Houston Parks
Board, partners like the Buffalo Bayo Partnership,
all of our partners, and then we look I think we have to look extensively
past and beyond what we could do internally.
And then from a study standpoint,
we do our needs assessment, evaluate that,
and then we just come together and figure out where the gaps are, and we
redevelop the Parks master plan. I think
our last plan was 2016,
and we're currently trying to get to the point
where we update that by 2024
for our accreditation through NRPA.
We need a solid master plan to
present to receive our accreditation. So we'll be working on
that aggressively in the next year. And the tennis program will
be part of that, sir? Absolutely. Tennis has taken
a unique, I would say,
position right now because we invited prose
consultant a few years ago to come in and do kind
of a study on where we are and where we need to go. We have
a draft document that we're tweaking now that we'll unleash
with the help of zena Garrison who we hired as our tennis
manager. There it is. Can you say that again out loud?
There's the first time I've heard that. Zena Garrison we hired as
our outreach and our manager for tennis.
So she's coordinating with our new deputy assistant
director, tom Angelos, who is in the room. We're going to work together
on that plan and finalize it,
which will also encompensate our master plan that we have to
produce and
submit to receive our accreditation by 24, I believe.
Is that the right date? Yeah. Amazing. Well, you said Zena
Garrison. I'm excited about that. Thank you for mentioning it. The other two words
to say I think I just heard council member alcorn say it.
Pickleball. Yeah.
I'm going to challenge you all to try pickleball.
We're planning on using the sport of pickleball.
It's similar to tennis, and we're going to actually
provide an opportunity for the public to play. We hope
to establish about 30 courts throughout Houston combined
with tennis. It's a unique sport.
It's fast paced. There are several different
division. Tom Angelos are newly hired.
Well, he's been on for almost a year now. He's a
pickleball advocate. And we're promoting not only developing courts
with tennis, but also programming along the way.
We're hosting the national pickleball tournament in October
at memorial park. So when we get closer to that date, I would
love for you guys to come out and take a look at it. Absolutely.
Thanks again, director, you vice mayor pro TEM
Martha castex Tatum. Thank you, chair director Allen,
thank you so much for your presentation. I heard you say that
esplanades were the third priority after
the parks and some other services and then our esplanades. I was
driving home on yesterday along Kirby.
I usually go on 59, but I went down Kirby because the freeway is closed
at 610 and I saw a group of contractors putting
down turf in the esplanade, and I thought that
was a genius idea. So my question is,
what's your thoughts on turf in the esplanades?
And I noticed that along that Kirby street
headed towards holcomb, there are lots of trees, so the
grass doesn't grow there. So I know they were putting that artificial
turf down because they can't get the grass to grow there. But it looked amazing.
I said I was going to go back down that way today to see what
the. Finished product looked like, but there was a whole crew there,
and they were putting down turf in the esplanade.
I'm interested to know your thoughts on that, because if that's a
thing, I'd be interested in having
some artificial turf and some espionage in District A.
That's a pretty amazing idea. We have some wonderful partnerships
with neighborhoods in terms of taking care of
their espinates. It's called the adopt Espinate
program. And so there's some great ideas. Turf is very expensive
to put down up front, but you don't have to maintain it.
So I like to explore that idea even more. I'll go
by there today and take a picture of the finished product and send it to
you, and we can explore that a little more. I'll appreciate it.
All right. Council Member Carolyn Evans Shabaz.
Thank you, Mayor Pro. Tim. Thank you so much. Director Allen.
We've had a lot of engagement about our park
rich, District D. I wanted to ask,
how often are the esplanades cut?
I just got a call, and they're saying that they think
they need to be cut every two weeks. I don't know what kind of cycle
they are on, and maybe it depends on where they're located.
We're actually on a 28 day cycle for espionage,
but I think every two weeks is a little much to
be able to maintain for a full city. So I was just curious.
So it's a 28 day cycle, at least 28 days. But many
of our espionage are adopted by civic clubs and neighborhood
groups, and so that's been great. In some areas.
It's kind of like having a garden and having volunteers
kind of maintain it. We do have standards, and there's a process
for adopting an espinate. I encourage communities
to get involved with that. It's certainly a way to keep neighborhoods
beautified. In terms of volunteerism,
my last question, how do the sectors factor in
to money? Because I know that we have a lot of parks,
but we don't get as much money in regards to the sectors.
The park sectors are specific to the development that's
happening in those sectors, and monies are allotted to that
specific sector. I've had recent conversations
with legal about how we can possibly
even the playing field in terms of
money and development throughout this city. We are looking
at some potential options that we could get into in terms
of sharing in the future. But I don't have a document for you guys just
yet, but we're looking into that. Okay, thank you very much.
Thank you. Council Member Mary NAN Huffman.
Thank you, Director, for everything that you do. How many escalades are
adopted, do you know?
Mr. Gonzalez?
About 1000 acres. Okay. And you've talked about the
program, the Adopt an Esplanade program,
but I don't see a lot of advertising for it. What do we do to
encourage civic associations and homeowners associations to engage
in that program? Oh, definitely, if you guys have newsletters,
put them in your newsletters online,
and we can develop a campaign to actually assist
with that from our communications office. But I think
it's a great idea to get more exposure toward that program.
And then also, if one esplanade is adopted,
what does that equal in savings for the city?
Or is it by acre? Oh, our expense
per acre is about mr.
Gonzalez 2828
$2800 per acre. Thank you.
Council Member Robert Gallegos.
Thank you, Mayor, for Tim. Director, in regards to I know there's a
y'all are in need of lifeguards. I am so
glad you brought that up. Are we
we have 37 pools throughout this city,
and I would love to open all of them. You guys know
last year we only opened ten.
This year, we're scheduled to do just
about that. Again, there's just a shortage. We don't have
the same amount of
young men and women coming out to lifeguard.
They're choosing other things. Our workforce used to
be about 50% return, but after we closed pools,
we lost that workforce, and we're aggressively trying to regain
it. But for a young
adult starting at 16, we have
opportunities anywhere from a pool supervisor to a head
lifeguard and a lifeguard. And we take this profession very
seriously because you're responsible for lives in that pool.
We want to operate safely, and we want to make sure we have everything we
need at each location. So if we were to open a
day, it would be about ten or eleven pools.
We're aggressively recruiting and asking for help so
that we can open more. And we'll do that from a
strategic standpoint. In terms of attendance in the past,
we may go to a rotating schedule. Two pools open
on this side of town or in this district, and then maybe Tuesday,
Thursday, and then two on another side, maybe Wednesday,
Friday. But we have to get creative in providing these services
across the city with what we have in terms of staffing resources.
But we're aggressively recruiting right now, and I'm hoping you reach out
to the District council members so that way we can have input as to what
pools we think should be opened. I know Clinton Park has already
reached out to me, and there's no other pool in the area,
so I think Clinton Park would be a great pool to open in
District I. And my last question here,
looking at the demographic breakdown again,
with nearly half the population being Hispanic, only 29%
are employed by the Parks Department are Hispanic.
So I'm hoping that there can be some improvement on that.
And if you could also please provide me with a breakdown of the
demographic breakdown for the management of
the Parks Department, I would appreciate it.
Thank you. Certainly. Council member Abby Cayman.
Thank you, Mayor. Pro TEM. Really quickly, director,
one thing that's been on my mind here in Houston we talk a lot about
flooding, as we should, but we also
have cyclical droughts. 87% of
the state right now, and I think over half of Houston itself is actually in
a drought. Are those costs calculated
in, or how much more cost is it when we're dealing with
a drought? So having to water more?
Again, 2011 cost millions of dollars in Memorial
Park alone from the loss of trees. So if you could just speak
to that really quickly in terms of that cost calculation.
As far as the cost breakdown, I don't have any history from
previous droughts. I just know we had to recover.
We had to do specific things in terms of soil, in terms
of plants, in terms of placement, but I
don't have any data that could support it at this point. I could certainly do
a little bit of research with our green space team and
get you something specific, no problem. And then lastly,
council member Robinson, I think me and director Allen could definitely
take you and council member Alcorn on in a doubles
with pickleball. So let us know whenever you want. We'll be
there. What time is session over with?
Thank you. Anytime you guys would like to, just let me know.
We have five public speakers. Before that, I'd like to go to slide
eight that's on the list. And it's about Memorial Park Golf Course.
I had the opportunity to play Saturday. I went there for the beginning of the
first tea event they had over there. And I just wanted to highlight
we get 1.1 million $333,000
as a gift from the Astros Foundation. I love the fact that
you all aerated and put some sand all over the course. And we really need
to have that course, as you know, in great shape in November
for the tournament, because if you remember last
year, it wasn't in good shape. And there was a quote in a Sunday paper
that when we all picked it up and reread it, we were embarrassed by it,
and that was the winner of the tournament. Jason Cocrot was
quoted as saying, I would have shot seven shots better
if I wasn't hitting off of mud all day. So as
Memorial Park golf Course, so goes the rest of the golf courses in
the city because we use the proceeds and we fund a lot of our operations
with that. So I see a lot of good work out there. So thank you
for that. Director. One thing that I did talk to Ms. Julie Blum
about is summer jobs program. Texas A
and M has a great golf turf management school.
Have we reached out to them, or does it make sense that we do reach
out to them and try and get some of those young kids that
are studying turf grass science and come to Memorial
and spend a summer? It look good on their
resume that they worked on a PGA tournament golf course.
And I think we have hard time attracting
employees out there right now because we just don't,
quite frankly, pay enough. And they get other opportunities
at other golf courses all around the city. So we're disadvantaged
right there. But using some of those Texas A and M kids, I think
would make a good sense to get that course ready,
because the growing season is upon us,
and if we don't have it ready in November,
the Houston Open will not be at Memorial Park.
Again, my opinion and many other people's opinions.
So we're doing a great job of trying to get it there, but I want
to raise that warning flag and say we have to nail
it in November. If we do nail it, we get
an opportunity, a golden opportunity, to move it to April.
And what happens in April, we don't compete against football.
We don't compete against basketball, and we don't compete against
baseball. And our attendance numbers will zoom,
and the higher they go, the more money we will receive from the Astros Golf
Foundation. So any comments on that?
Last year was unfortunate in terms of some
of the results of maintenance of the course, I believe
we made those adjustments to move forward. We're currently
looking for a senior superintendent that we're working
with, the Astros Golf Foundation as well
as a PGA. I think we have qualified and great
staff there. Now in terms of maintenance
of the course, we won't have the issues that we had last year with the
Greens and their approach shots. Major focus.
If you see the Agronomy plan that we're working on now,
you can already see improvements. So I'm confident
that we will meet the standard that we need to meet this year because
we're making adjustments accordingly, and I know you will. So thank you for
that. Council Member Carolyn Evan Shabaz.
Thank you, Mayor. For. Tim and I did want to take this time to tell
you thank you as well. We had our first Te graduation
on this past Saturday. It was great. We had 16 students
that participated in a program for a few weeks, and you
were the impetus for that idea, you and Steven,
my constituents director. The young people really
enjoyed it, and more importantly, they have opportunities to maintain the
game and perhaps get scholarships. And so that's
so very important. So I wanted to make sure that I did thank you
for that. Thank you. We have five
public speakers. Same rules apply for this session as last.
First we'll have Miss Saba blinding Director.
Thank you for your comments, and I appreciate it. Thank you very much.
Hello. Good morning. First. Before I forget, I wanted to
follow on Council member Alcorn and Council member Cayman's comments
about drought. And I love the idea of putting some more native
grasses and native plants in our esplanades, in our cross
just to help.
And also, I wanted to speak on behalf of my ten year old, who could
not be here this morning due to testing. She would love to see
more skate parks in the city of Houston. She is a great fan
of the Lee and Joe Jamel skate park as well as the lessons you offer
through them. And she also shared a desire for more gardens like the
McGovern Centennial Gardens. She also asked about sidebalks
and I told her that was a whole nother bag.
And just as a mom, I cannot say
enough good things about the Parks Department. I frequently have conversations
with other parents discussing both of our love for Houston
parks programming and a desire for more as they quickly fill up once
open to the public. Just a quick anecdote.
A friend of mine once shared the long list of incredible Houston camps
his sons attended and that of all of them, the Cherryhurst
camp through the Parks Department was their favorite. And they liked it so much that
the next summer it was the only program they signed up for.
And I could say more and more about what parents talk about. Thank you,
Ms. Blanding. Thank you. We're running behind already.
Could I just a quick question. 5 seconds. Okay, thinking citywide.
What would it look like to expand and grow current programming equitably
across the city? So thank you for the question and
we are directing director Allen and Ms. Johnson that
we will field all the questions. So we will go ahead and
take that. If anybody has any answers to Ms.
Blanding's question on council, please feel free to
chime in. But as a good teacher would say,
you're dismissed. I just want to know what it would
be look like. I mean, I can't say enough good things about the programming and
so what would it look like to expand it more equitably
across the city of Houston? Getting tongue tied today.
I mean, funds are limited. I'll give you an example. We have no city run
parks in Kingwood, and we have one city run park in Clear Lake.
So I have one. And we have Lake
Houston Wilderness Park, which is the most underappreciated
park in the city, maybe in the south,
but I think that a lot of it comes
from you all. South in the US. I think
a lot of it comes from you all based on the dynamics and the circumstances
of each district, understanding what the needs are of each neighborhood
and what you would like to see from a programming standpoint as well as a
recreational standpoint. And so we
lean on you all to let us know as your council members
on what you would like to see within your own footprint. And then we will
work within ourselves, either through our council district service funds or directly with
the Parks Department on trying to find ways to
improve parks with those specialty needs. Yes, and if you
have any ideas, please send them to us. We will make sure that we pass
them along and then we will give them to your appropriate council member as well.
Because as we keep talking about, we do have council district
service funds that we can use for some of our parks activities.
I know we use some at our Sylvan Rodriguez Park down
south. I appreciate the invitation. Yes,
ma'am. Mr. Council Member Robert Gallegos.
I'm sorry.
First of all, thank you for being here. Appreciate you being here.
I know that Mayor Turner has the 50
50 parks. He's reaching out to corporations to
hopefully put some monies in parks that have been neglected
in many of our districts. I know that at
Hartman Park there in Manchester, we were able to get valero.
That was the first 50 50 park. They were able to put monies for
new play equipment because I kid you not, some of their play, the play equipment
was rusting. And a lot
of people are surprised on the cost of play equipment.
It was about $660,000
for new play equipment at at Hartman Park. So that that's
what we're running into is that the cost is just so expensive.
And I've got a request at Fondi Park last week at my
redistricting that they're just looking for new swings.
I asked them, do you need the whole play equipment? They said, no, we just
need new swings. So I'm going to put in the cost to the
parks department to see just how much do swings cost.
And I'm afraid to hear the price tag just for swings,
but I'm going to try to do that at Fondue Park as
well. Thank you, Mr. Landing. Thank you,
Mr. Jason Oliver. Thank you.
So I just got here late during the last presentation,
but I wanted to ask, why is council
fielding our questions instead of the because every committee I let
it get away. That was my fault. I let it get away from us yesterday.
That's why we ran overtime. We're going to limit people to 1 minute like we
gave instructions on. And in every committee meeting we have in the city
of Houston, questions come to council members, not to
department directors. So we're going to keep with
that as elected officials. That's on us.
It's our budget process as well. So we're going to
go back to what I should have done yesterday and that was my fault.
So we won't be able to likely get the
answers to our questions or at least clear answers in time for the well,
hopefully you all can get answers back quickly. Yes. I mean, our path is within
48 hours, we get the questions posted, we get the answers.
And I would invite you to talk to your respective council member
and make sure you get those answers to those questions directed back
to you. Okay. In the past, the parks
department has said that they can easily double you soccer participation
with just a few more staff to administer the program. Your general
fund spend is about 200,000. Basically the same as five years ago.
Is there an opportunity to still reach an additional 50,000 students
through that programming? And I also want to know how competitive lifeguard pay
is. So I'll take our lifeguard pay.
That's why we're having trouble right now. Is it's not competitive,
especially with some of the different swim clubs that we have
around that pay a little bit more than we do. So you
answer your question. It's not competitive enough to
answer your question. I think it was about soccer. Yeah, a lot of the
soccer fields in the city of what's that?
$11 an hour? A lot
of the soccer fields I'm a soccer dad. All three of my kids,
13 to 16, is the official answer.
Director Allen competitive? Correct me if I'm wrong. Your question is
about soccer fields. A lot of our soccer fields are leased to a lot
of these soccer organizations, and we monitor the activity on them.
So if they're leased, they actually control the soccer fields like
the Houston Golf Association controls Gus Worthham
Park. So it's up to those folks to decide. Oh, no,
my question was because the soccer program is
grant funded, and in the past they've said that they
could double the participation with more General Fund dollars for administration.
The the limitation is, is General Fund spend on administration,
not for. So that could easily ramp up.
I'm trying to figure out if that's still the case, if we still are kind
of leaving students out when we could allocate another
quick 200,000 to really ramp up our soccer
participation for children in Houston. Right. And thank you.
We will post that question and get that question answered.
Lauren Johnson.
Hi. So the after school
enrichment program currently operates at 51 community
centers locations throughout the Houston area, and they
service about 2500 youth with a ratio of 1.25.
So where is that in terms of adequate or optimal staffing?
And how could we strategically fund that expansion in the
short term? Anyone want
to take this one on?
Okay, we will get that answer posted. And I would invite
you to get in touch with your council member for the
answer to that question. Once again,
public speakers should submit their questions in writing,
and then we will get in writing a written response back to you within
48 hours to your particular district
council member or at large.
Joe Grochell so
my question is, the Parks Department seems to be on par with the libraries
in its significant community reach and impact.
And how many Houstonians do you think you are able to serve
with every dollar?
Apparently not enough parks are I
told you about my experience. We have no Houston parks in the area that I
live in. We have one Houston park in the area that is
Clear Lake, and there's a great deal of
demand. Fortunately, we have good county parks in both
of those areas that we partner with in many, many ways county
has done a fantastic job. My opinion of
building parks in and around the city of Houston, in the ETJ
areas, the city of Houston, we struggle a
little bit because of the lack of funds that we have available,
but we do the best job that we can given the fact that the
funds are not as plentiful as they should be.
And if anyone wants to make a foundation donation,
I would contact the great number of foundations we have in and around the city
that are very philanthropic with their efforts, and contact
them and adopt a neighborhood program to adopt a neighborhood park.
We've done that in the area that I live in. We're responsible
for the mowing of the grass, the new soccer equipment,
and we even had a fundraiser for the lights that we put up. Now,
not every community has the ability to do that.
I get it. But I think philanthropic areas
of funding, we have a great number of folks
in and around this Houston area. I'll throw out the Brown
Foundation. That has been very good to us in many regards.
Thank you.
Melissa Martinez.
Hello. Hi. So I have a couple of
questions. My questions about accessibility,
such as how have the needs have changed for youth
and elders programming during the Pandemic and also
for our disability communities?
And how do staff and support needed to support these equitable
access to these programs? And also
mentioned in slide 27 in the budget, I noticed
that there was an investment of 14 million and improved 18 neighborhoods,
parks, and community centers. What would the impacts be if budgets
were to be doubled, say, like 28 million to help with these accessibility?
I think the Mayor's 50 50 initiative is right on target with
exactly what you're doing, especially in complete communities.
That's been our emphasis. Community is only as good
as the parks around it, and giving young people the
opportunity to participate with funding of nice
parks is one of the initiatives that we're front and
center with what we're trying to do. Council Member David Robinson. Thank you. I just
wanted to mention to Ms. Martinez that our Director of the Mayor's Office
for Persons with Disabilities, Gabe Cassidas, recently presented
to the TTI committee that we chair. And that presentation did talk
about accessibility generally, but also within
the context of parks access. So you may find that posted on the city website
under the TTI committee heading, and I
think you might find that helpful considering your question.
Okay. I know Director Allen. We made a lot of adjustments during the Pandemic.
We took the basketball goals down. We did a lot of things.
If I made the statement that we're pretty close to where we were
pre Pandemic, is that accurate? Yes.
Okay. So I think you'll see more and more of that where,
especially when the summer rolls through, hopefully we can get the lifeguards out.
It's going to be a hot summer. It's going to be a dry summer.
It was funny because many of us went to
a Houston prayer breakfast this morning. I know many of our officers did as well.
And Mr. Herzog from one of the TV stations was
talking about the drought and the conditions and how he hates it. And I was
the only one that actually love a drought because love in a
drought means we have no storms coming yet and
we need to be prepared because the area that I live in was
pretty devastated, as is council member Jackson's.
But Abby came and shaking her head, no, but I love droughts.
Difference of opinion. Thank you. We will now transition.